los líderes europeos llegaron ayer al
típico acuerdo que suele ocurrir en la
Unión Europea para empezar un poco de
todo que pueda convencer a todos los
gobiernos los líderes europeos aprobaron
poner un límite flexible a las compras
de gas natural es decir si por ejemplo
en el mercado hay un determinado precio
que fluctúa de forma de que esté por
encima del tope acordado Entonces no se
va a comprar este gas una medida que se
espera pueda reducir los precios que
ahora mismo están en niveles muy altos
por otra parte los líderes europeos
Después de varias horas de negociaciones
de más de 10 horas en concreto
finalmente Se abrieron a estudiar la
posibilidad de poner un límite al precio
del gas que genera electricidad una
medida muy controvertida países como
Alemania o Países Bajos no estaban de
acuerdo hasta ahora para finalmente el
canciller Alemán
a que la comisión europea pueda hacer un
análisis una investigación y pueda
analizar los pros y de que esta medida
se puede aplicar en toda Europa Porque
ahora mismo solo está en España y
Portugal finalmente también los líderes
aprobaron compras conjuntas de gas tal y
como se hizo con las vacunas La idea es
que con la fuerza negociadora del propio
bloque puedan intentar negociar para
reducir los precios de este gas ahora
los ministros de energía de nuevo se
tendrán que reunir la semana que viene
para poder cerrar todos los detalles
técnicos de este acuerdo y bajar de una
vez los precios de la energía que se
encuentran en máximos históricos hoy los
líderes europeos se vuelven a reunir
aquí en Bruselas abordan ahora mismo las
relaciones con China y también la ayuda
a Ucrania